en el primer aniversario del paro
nacional se volvieron a ver imágenes que
recordaron a las protestas más grandes
en décadas en colombia pero fueron muy
puntuales como estas de la universidad
nacional de bogotá a la capital
por lo que la jornada en gran parte del
país tuvo más aire de conmemoración que
de combate y reunió a estudiantes
trabajadores y activistas todos con la
mente en 2021 precisamente ese estallido
social de levantamiento popular que
seguido el 28 abril del 2021 y que hoy
justamente conmemoramos un año es
producto también de todo ese cansancio
con este modelo con este gobierno duque
y pues es una reacción digamos natural
que tenemos desde los pueblos salir a
movilizarnos protestas que se
extendieron durante meses y dejaron un
alto coste humano con denuncias contra
las fuerzas de seguridad de violar los
derechos humanos acusados de ser
responsables de la muerte de al menos 40
civiles
el estallido social había iniciado con
una reforma tributaria que afectaba a
las clases medias y bajas pero con el
paso de los días se le sumaron demandas
que iban desde una mayor igualdad hasta
la reivindicación de implementar los
acuerdos de paz recordemos que este paro
nacional estuvo muy participativo la
juventud estudiantil y entonces todas
las reformas en la parte educativa
ninguna
la población campesina que se movilizó
por el tema de seguridad del territorio
ninguna retos que presumiblemente
quedarán para el próximo presidente el
29 de mayo es la primera vuelta de la
elección presidencial con el
izquierdista gustavo petro favorito para
llevar a cabo las demandas de reformas
estructurales mientras el candidato de
derecha federico gutiérrez es visto como
el continuismo